many churches and other houses of
worship
around the country will remain closed
for services this weekend
because of the pandemic the potter's
house mega church
led by bishop t.d jakes is among them
the congregation with 30 000 members has
suspended
in-person church activities until
further notion notice bishop t.d jakes
joins us now
from dallas bishop it's so great to see
you thanks for being with us
oh thanks for having me anthony faith
and worship
so much of that is about is about
community how do we maintain community
when we're being asked to be in
isolation
you know i think it's uh we have the
extreme advantage of technology so
whether we're streaming
whether we're checking on people through
facebook or
instagram or twitter or what have you
we're able to establish some level of
community that we didn't have before
and i think we have to be intentional
about being connected
uh spiritually even if we're not
connected physically
yeah the surgeon general said the other
day bishop dr jerome adams
social distancing does not mean social
disengagement
to follow up on what anthony said
because you are a good person to call in
time of need
what are the best ways that we can feel
connected and still maintain
social distancing i think a lot of
people are struggling with that
i understand that i think it's very
important that first of all
a lot of people are hunkered down with
their families
and we don't spend a lot of time with
our families and i think it's a great
time
to reinstill your core values to have
some devotional or meditation
during this time to check on the people
you love whether you do it by phone or
by text we have to be intentional about
readjusting our values
and our priorities because we're shut
down from work or what have you
but that doesn't mean that we don't have
anything to do and to take on it
on this uh take this opportunity as a
time to
engage with people intentionally that we
normally don't get to spend
quality time with is very important
bishop as wonderful as technology
is it really is no replacement for a
warm human presence for meeting somebody
in person so you can understand why some
churches are
open still and why some people still
want to be going to those churches even
if it means being in a group
what's your message to those
organizations and those people today
well you know every area is different in
texas we have a
state mandate that not over 10 people be
assembled together and if they are
assembled they have to be distant i
think that we have to
obey and follow the rules as they come
down from
our scientists from our doctors or from
our political powers and entities
but the fact that we don't engage
physically i know that that's a loss
it's a great loss for every pastor
there's not any pastor
out there that doesn't want to see his
congregation but that does not mean that
we cannot express
love that we cannot maintain some level
of connectivity
and then be cognizant of the fact that
this is going to pass over this is a
temporary
circumstance it may be longer than we
like it may be more difficult than we
like
but we have to look beyond the breach of
where we are right now
and remember who we are as a people
bishop so many people are already
feeling a financial strain
from this and i'm sure some churches are
too what what impact are you seeing at
this point
oh yes you know i think across the board
uh it is difficult to maintain the kind
of
financial uh impact that we normally
would have and that's a problem because
right now
churches really want to embrace a
community we're
feeding people we're serving people
we're reaching out to people in need
and we help to keep some sort of
equilibrium in the sociological fiber of
our community
if we don't have the resources to do
that that becomes difficult
but we've been very creative and we've
been able to keep it going so far
and i think many many churches both
small and large we
face different types of challenges but
we have been able
uh to keep one another going so far well
bishop at my house there's nobody but me
myself and i and i'm getting on my own
damn nerves
what do you say to people because i know
you're a loving kind man
what do you say to people when your
loved ones are getting on your nerves
how do you navigate that as happy as we
all love each other that's what you use
that's when you use distancing as an
excuse to retreat into your cage and go
back out
when you're feeling better you say the
coronavirus is waking us
up what do you mean by that waking us up
how
i think it is uh caused us to rethink
uh the tribalism that's been so
pervasive in our society today
how we have slipped into tribalism as it
relates to politics as it relates to
race as it relates to age
uh we have thought about just about
everything imaginable
and now we have a common enemy and
there's nothing like a common enemy to
bring about unity
and i think it's a clarion call to bring
about unity amongst humanity
and also i think it's a resurgence of
faith because
we cannot see and we have to trust what
we cannot see
and i think there is a resurgence and a
renewal that america and around the
world is being called to
to re-examine our values our priority in
our faith you say that believing in god
does not
mean that you negate common sense why is
that so important
oh you know i think it's very very
important sometimes people
are confused what it means to have faith
and i think but we still have to use
wisdom
as well and one does not negate the
other uh we can still believe god and
still practice
uh distancing we can still have faith uh
we don't want to
tempt faith jesus during the 40 days in
the wilderness was offered by the enemy
chances to
tempt faith if you're really the son of
god throw yourself off the cliff
and that type of mentality is not very
helpful during this time
so we don't need people to teach the
kind of faith uh to the peril and the
destruction of others we want to use the
kind of faith
that unites us that connects us that
feels continuity and love
not extremism all right bishop td jakes
thank you very much we hope you'll come
back and
visit us when circumstances allow yes
always good to see you i look forward to
it
we do too thank you thanks bishop have a
good day